a covid19 vaccine shortage another
hurdle the state faces
in the fight against coronavirus viewers
were already expressing frustration in
nevada's slow rollout of the vaccine
we do thank you for joining us at six
i'm brian loftus
and i'm denise valdez the i-team's
vanessa murphy has been
digging for answers and is live now with
more details tonight vanessa
brian and denise some viewers are having
trouble
scheduling appointments for the covid19
vaccine
now we know one reason why state
officials
are talking about a vaccine shortage
i'm like wait a minute you know what's
what's going on here 66 year old shirley
bryce is frustrated with nevada's
vaccine rollout
in my age group a lot of friends around
the country i see them getting
vaccinated
all over the place and i'm thinking what
is wrong with nevada
the state's kovid 19 response director
points to a vaccine
shortage this is a function of what
we've been talking about for some time
which is
our allocation from the federal
government is not enough
to meet our needs or our capacity at the
state level caleb cage
says he hopes that will change through
the biden administration
he reports for the past five weeks
nevada's received approximately 36
thousand doses a week
but the goal is to administer 18
thousand doses
a day he points to the cashman center
which is now
closed friday through the weekend cage
says there may not be enough doses to
keep the downtown las vegas
mega vaccination site running each day
in the meantime he says some doses are
available at other locations for smaller
groups
they want to make sure that with the
allocation and the doses that they have
available
that their local partners get an
opportunity to run their
their programs as well the cdc has
reported the state
lags behind in vaccinating nevadans on
friday the state reported that more than
137 thousand nevadans received the
vaccine
in a population of close to 3 million on
january 11th governor steve sisilak
announced the state would toss out the
tier system
and move to lanes prioritizing frontline
workers the same time as vulnerable
groups
still appointments are being offered for
ages 70
plus seniors like bryce wait
so many of us are living like hermits we
are absolutely terrified to go outside
so will nevada start receiving a larger
amount of doses
eventually if the federal government
approves another vaccine down the line
but
as far as right now there really isn't a
clear
answer state officials find out how many
doses nevada will receive
the week before they arrive reporting
live vanessa murphy
8 news now